bed and if you believe it  it's true  that's why you can't argue with these  people but that's why people have like  schizophrenia and stuff like that they  create a world in their head and they  believe that they are going through all  of these things and this is why they get  medicated  because doctors know that that's  actually not reality what these people  are doing is saying okay the reality  that you've created in your head  yeah we'll make that your reality it's  crazy  it's actually insane and  oh my gosh because i don't know how you  could be this old like this is an old  lady and still believe that like i'm 25.  you know what i mean i'm like nanosphere  gold you know  she's got primates 25 and childless and  i'm almost going to hit my wall  someone's going to  snap you up soon you would think right  but but but no and i feel like at 25  i have a better grasp on reality than  this old lady yeah how should  unfortunately this shouldn't be